what what's tricky to decide between the
illusion of time so there are certain
theories in well there's certain
interpretations of time such as Carlo
rivelli's there's Julian Barbers we'll
get to them what does the PBR theorem
have to say about relational quantum
mechanics
yeah so so yeah you you did give me some
warning you were going to ask that
question and and I afraid I just have to
say I don't understand relational
quantum mechanics I've looked at it a
bit I talked to Carl about it a bit I
just don't understand it
I know some people who've looked at it
more carefully and they were unable to
find what they considered a coherent
formulation of it
um if you feel like you understand it
then you can explain it to me and I can
try to respond if you feel like you
don't really understand it and can just
repeat what other people say we're a bit
stuck
uh I just I just don't understand what
the theory claims even apart from time
and then my issue here isn't about time
um
I I don't understand what it means to
say that all that's real are relations
it's I mean sometimes there's this tag
phrase that people say oh relations
without rolata and this is you know
you're just contradicting how can you
have a relation without relata or
um things only exist when they interact
and then you want to say but wait if
they weren't already there how could
they interact
I mean how can how can interaction occur
between two things that don't exist
um I I don't I literally don't
understand what's being claimed
um I once I mean I can uh if and again
if you feel like you want to explain it
to me I'm I'm all ears I I will again
one one little data point was was once I
was puzzled about stuff talking to Carla
and we were talking about non-locality
right so in the non-locality case Alice
does an experiment over here and Bob
does an experiment very far away and the
issue is the correlations between the
outcomes of the experiments they do
right that that's what Bell's inequality
puts constraints on on these
correlations
and uh
as far as I could understood Carlos
seemed to be saying that that
uh there is no outcome for Bob
just you can't just talk about what
happened in Bob's lab right you normally
think you could you say okay Bob did an
experiment did he get a DOT here or a
DOT there you know was it an up or down
outcome and it's like no no no he only
had an outcome relative to Alice and
furthermore somehow that outcome only
occurs when Alice and Bob interact and
Alice and Bob only interact when after
the experiment they come back together
and share data or something like that
and and I said but I don't understand
Carlos so if I'm Bob
and I do my experiment right and I have
my data and then I'm waiting for Alice
Alice's to come meet me to share her
data and Alice comes and she says you
know uh 10 minutes ago I just got this
result
do I not believe her
I mean do I literally just not believe
yes you got that result 15 minutes ago
long before I ever found out about it
and long before we ever interacted
and and Carl just looked at me like I
had asked a question that never occurred
to him I mean he didn't have a ready
answer at the time I don't know if he
does now and at that point I said I just
don't understand I mean I think Alice is
there doing her experiments and getting
her outcomes and Bob is there doing his
experiments and getting his outcomes
quite even though they're not
interacting with each other
in a normal sense of interaction
um
and those outcomes are what they are and
they do or they do not violate Bell's
inequality
I don't understand what the relational
Theory says about that case I have some
puzzlement because I asked Carlo well
what's being related and then I believe
he said certain relations then I said
well what are those relating and is it
not just some infinite regress of
relations and then he said yes
oh yeah
but but
it looks very is is maybe it's honest
it's kind of fun I mean there's a Dr
Seuss story
about the about about the lazy bees and
Hodge hatch right so um so you know they
they find that when the B Watcher
watches the bees they're they're busier
so they hire a b Watcher but the B
Watcher was lazy so they had to hire a b
Watcher Watcher and then if you watch or
watch her to watch the be Watcher and
and
um you know it's the same thing people
say well you know reality doesn't exist
until an observer observes something and
you say but wait did The Observer
already exist
oh no no The Observer only exists
because some super Observer was
observing The Observer but did the super
Observer already exist oh no there had
to be a super super Observer and then
you said this is just silly I mean you
know why are you doing this you just
watched a clip from the theories of
everything channel for the full video
and all its magnificence then click here
and if you'd like to see more then
subscribe enjoy